-Our next guest is a talente
actor you know from such shows
as "The Good Lord Bird"
and "Lodge 49."
He stars as John Walker in "Th
Falcon and the Winter Soldier,
which is available to stream
on Disney+
with the season finale episode
available this Friday.
Let's take a look.
-Stop the car!
[ Brakes squeal ]
-Look. I -- I get it.
Okay? I get the attitude. I do
You didn't think that the shield
was going to end up here.
I get it, Bucky.
And I'm -- I'm not trying
to be Steve.
I'm not trying to replace Steve.
I'm just trying to be the best
Captain America I can be.
That's it.
And it would be
a whole lot easier
if I had Cap's wingmen
on my side.
-[ Scoffs ]
It's always that last line
-Please welcome to the sho
Wyatt Russell.
How are you, Wyatt?
-Hey, how is it going?
-I'm so very happy
to have you here.
I did not know this about you.
I knew, obviously,
you came from an acting family
and I became familiar
with you as an actor,
but you actually set out to be
a professional hockey player
-Yeah. It was a long journey
from Los Angeles.
I moved to Vancouver to play
when I was about 15.
Moved to a million places
after that --
Colorado, Alabama,
Toronto, Vancouver.
And I played my professional
hockey in Germany and Holland,
which I know that you spen
some time there as well.
-Yeah.
-I lived in Groningen.
-Groningen?
-Yeah. [ Chuckles ]
-So, yeah, I was living in
Amsterdam in my 20s.
And you were living in
Groningen, which is worse.
-Which is worse.
Which is a little worse.
It was really cool 'cause it was
like a different...
Amsterdam, as you know,
is this sort of melting po
of all different types
of cultures
and it's kind of
an insane place.
Where I was living
was like a college town.
It was really cool.
I lived in the red light
district in that town.
And so it was a really different
experience for me.
But we didn't --
I couldn't partake
in a lot of the fun stuff
that everybody else may have
because we were drug teste
and, you know,
we couldn't lose our minds
So I don't think we were doing
necessarily the same thing
when we were there.
-Yeah, probably stayed safe.
Probably though if you're in
a college town in Groningen,
there was
a fair amount of Heineken.
I'm guessing you were at least
drinking that on tap.
-Oh, yeah.
The Heineken cool bar.
Absolutely.
-You're playing a characte
in this show that is, I guess,
safe to say, not a fan favorite.
But that must be
one of the parts
that makes it
so much fun to play
this maybe villainous elements
-Yeah. It's -- It's a blast.
Part of what it was
when I had my interview
with the producers
and the director
was trying to figure out
something different to do
to bring to Captain Americ
or the Marvel Universe
in some way that I thought could
be maybe unique.
Just 'cause, you know,
you're entering
like a pretty big machine
and as a cog in a wheel,
you want to help it work,
make it good.
And so that was the aim.
And that's the...
[ Chuckles ]
The elicited response
that has been from
the Marvel fan universe
is pretty great.
It's kind of awesome.
You know, minus
the fear of life and limb,
it's pretty good.
-I mean, I will say
it's nice because, again,
you obviously have a beard
I've seen with you a beard i
acting roles,
so at least you must be
slightly anonymous
because you're walking aroun
with a beard
you don't have in the show
-Nobody knows. It's amazing.
No one -- I have not been
recognized one time.
I swear to God. Not one time
I can go anywhere.
I went to a beach the other da
and I was like, you know,
it is a huge show and I get that
everybody's watch--
a lot of people are watching it.
But -- And I admit,
I like my anonymity.
So my fear is that you're gonn
walk into a place
and you're not gonna be able t
observe was going on.
It's part of my job.
I observe people
and then you see they're doing
and then copy this person that
you saw and they'll never know
And so that's been a fear.
I went to a beach
called Paradise Cove,
which is in Malibu.
If you've been there,
there's lots of people
on an Easter weekend.
And I was kind of nervous.
Like, "Oh, man,
I don't want to do this.
Might kind of
end up not so good."
I walked down --
Either I'm like,
terrible and everyone hates me
and no one wants to say hello,
or nobody recognizes
who I was
and just walking around
was amazing.
So I prefer it this way.
-You obviously wear --
It seems like people --
There's been a lot of meme
about the show.
That is not uncommon
with a Marvel project.
But this really -- It looks like
you look less like yoursel
and more like
the character in "Up."
[ Laughter ]
-I saw that.
The first time a friend sent i
on social media --
it filtered toward me
because it was too good --
I showed that to my wife,
and I thought we were going to
have a heart attack.
It so -- whoever --
It's perfect.
It's the most perfect.
[ Laughs ]
It's so good, man.
-It really --
And you find out --
You're like -- No.
I mean, don't ever
lose the beard, man,
'cause now you've got "Up" face.
[ Laughter ]
-I've to the a future
with the Marvel Universe
apparently for a very long time,
'cause I know Carl's pretty old.
-[ Laughs ] That's true.
[ Laughter ]
You also -- Congratulations.
You and your wife
just had a baby.
Four months old, is that right
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the best thing of all time.
It's everything
everyone says it is.
That's why everything you do
you do because
you want to spend more tim
with your kid.
It's been amazing.
-You named him Prine.
I'm a huge John Prine fan
myself.
So much so that I regretted that
it would make such a great name.
I'm assuming
that's why you did it?
-Well, for Mer and I,
we met playing music.
Music's a big part of our lives.
And John Prine was always
one of our favorites,
if not our favorite.
We sang "In Spite of Ourselves
at our wedding.
And he's a big part of it.
And around the time --
a big part of our relationship
And around the time that
we found out we were pregnant,
he had passed away.
And it was, as cheesy
as it sounds,
his lyrics in our life
have been kind of important.
He's always a person you can g
back to and you can listen to.
A song you've heard a hundre
times can take on new meanin
depending on
where you are in your life
And so we thought that Prine
was just a cool name.
First of all,
I like the way it sounds.
Bud Prine.
It's his middle name.
So if figured if everyone call
him Bud
and they wonder
why they know his name,
you can say, "Oh, you can
go by Prine if you want."
It's a cool name.
-It's a really nice tribut
and a really sweet thing
to hear.
Hey, man. Thanks so much.
It's really great to meet you.
And congrats on the show.
-Great to meet you too.
And take care.
-The season finale of "The
Falcon and the Winter Solider"
will be released this Friday
on Disney+.